this is a production of Cornell
University
so everyone welcome welcome to episode
seven of the Cornell Turf Show the
fastest uh 28 and a half minutes the in
Turf I think we're going to call it now
uh Our Guest today is Dr Mike credenza
of Penn State Berks Mike is going to be
on his book tour today we're going to
talk about Mike's new book uh
sustainable Turf price management we're
going to get to that today there he goes
he's got it ready locked and loaded so
he's done this tour a couple times uh
Frank Frank I'll bring you in to get us
started here uh to get your thoughts on
some of the things we're seeing out and
about these days
well first off big thanks to my pal Mike
Mike I appreciate that you taking the
time and we're going to do the best we
can to make this a really productive
book tour I think Carl's even got QR
codes ready for us uh to to get this
thing ordered so really happy to have
everybody here and thought I'd start off
with you know most looking for a good
dog picture I got another one later on
but nothing better than a dog on a hot
day sitting in a drainage ditch that's
working well uh there are very few
things more satisfying when a golf
course superintendent can put in some
drainage and actually see it working
right at it again right out of the gate
so
um Carl before I pass it to you uh our
New York's one of our great New York
State Golf Course superintendents of
personality and character unlike many
that I meet uh Thad Thompson in fact
we're going to be out walking and
talking at his brother's place in East
Aurora uh Drew's Place uh for a walk and
talk later in the year but Thad never
misses a moment for irony right he pumps
irony he's so good at it um this is uh
you gotta love this sign driving right
around it and oh and thad's comment was
well at least they didn't drive over it
Carl so with that I know you've got a
special Topic in plant planned for us
today in honor of our guests so let's uh
get it because it really ties in well
with what we're focused on here uh at
Cornell and the BMP stuff yeah I mean
you're exactly right Frank
sustainability that's sort of a big
umbrella term that a lot of people and a
lot of different walks of life use these
days uh you'll see this in our resources
last week we unveiled our sustainability
handbook you know we're talking about
each BMP and you get you guys have the
QR codes here for those watching you can
get each of these resources we've got
our sustainability handbook really about
awareness of best management practices
uh and then really happy to to have Mike
on today to talk about his new textbook
and he's the chief editor on achieving
sustainable turf grass management right
there's 20 chapters in here there's
stuff on drones there's stuff on
pollinators uh non-chemical control
diseases so there's a lot of cool stuff
in there there's six left on Amazon I
counted this morning Frank before I put
this QR code up here we're gonna see how
many are left after today but uh don't
worry that's right he could always print
more but I really wanted to talk really
in the up front here Frank about what is
sustainability right it's that big term
what is it I think about it in terms of
how golf courses what's the least we can
do to achieve our goal and I'm
highlighting here for those looking uh
the term least and the term goal right
sustainability doesn't start with all
the stuff the fertilizer the water the
pesticides it starts with our goal right
we need to define a goal and we have
some tools to do that nowadays yeah the
USGA just released uh this GS3 ball
right we've talked about about this on
the show a little bit that's going to
help us quantify uh putting green
quality smoothness firmness uh green
speeds right it's going to give a number
to that a lot of times I think when I
see people the goal as a superintendent
is you know Elite uh conditioning or
Championship quality uh what does that
mean right what what is that in terms of
a number a fairway ball eye like what
does that mean uh you got to Define your
goal right so I think that's the place
to start if your if your goal is a
conditioning from a superintendent from
a facility perspective maybe the goal is
to do rounds or Revenue we do this with
our state park courses we look at how
well they utilize available rounds so we
look at data that adjusts your rounds
capacity in a given year based on the
weather right if you have good or bad
weather that year you could do a maximum
number of rounds we look at the rounds
they did we call that percentage
utilization and maybe our goal is to
utilize the course better maybe our goal
is 55 percent running available two
times right so that's where it starts
sustainability starts with a goal and
then it's hey what am I putting into
that system to achieve that goal Frank
you looked at this in in the 2000s at
Bethpage green you guys asked the
question do we need pesticides on golf
courses uh the answer was yes you can't
remove pesticides and have a putting
green you figure that out pretty quickly
but one of the other things you figured
out is hey we can use less we could do
these reduced risk programs okay there's
a QR code if you want to look at this
document from the Bethpage green course
and we've transitioned that thinking
into all other state park golf courses
so this is data we look at with our
state park of course is about 15 courses
uh be tracked their pesticide risk eiq
you can measure that through you can
also measure it through the hazard
quotient now we've got data that
actually Compares our state park courses
to the national average
um so we know the national average and
this metric is around 260 right there's
the red line for those who can see and
State Park courses are well below that
that's good but hey can we go lower can
we still achieve our goals with less
pesticide use or in some cases hey maybe
we actually need to apply more in the
system to get enough golfers to get that
utilization right
um we can also look at fertilizer use
right so we have numbers from the gcfaa
here in the Northeast we've got those
numbers on the left our state park
courses on the right we use a lot less
fertilizer that's good
um but hey at each facility do we need
to use more do we need to use less
um in some cases hey maybe a little bit
more nitrogen on Fairways can help that
Turf quality improve and you get more
rounds out of it right there's a
marginal return maybe in in nitrogen so
our idea is what's the what's the least
we can do and get that goal out of it uh
and then one last one Frank is uh do we
need to maintain the property in a
homogeneous way or not uh Mike wrote a
great article in GCM the other day about
irrigation and the lazy the Malaysia
2005 paper which is taken out of context
a lot but one of the things you said in
there Mike is is about a third of the
total land on golf courses that is not
managed Turf and what we're asking is
can it be more do golfers really use all
of that 180 Acres on a landscape and
again we work with State Park courses to
implement these Nomo areas or native
areas lawn grass whatever you want to
call them uh hey there's this
peripheries at the golf course where
maybe we don't need to mow that as rough
twice a week so we've looked at across
those 15 golf courses about 300 acres
they've transitioned uh to this Lobo
native area
when we make some estimates on how much
they've reduced in mowing uh you know
this is sort of where sustainability
comes together okay 36 metric tons of
CO2 are diverted every year our
estimates
um because they've they've transitioned
to Lomo that's the same amount as 43
Acres of forest how much base sequester
carbony or the equivalent of driving
almost 91 000 miles in a gas powered
vehicle um and then at Cornell you know
we use some data to figure out hey where
are where are golfers actually going
right we've got data from uh the USGA
Deacon GPS system we strapped GPS people
put them in their pockets the golfers we
tracked them around the property we said
hey there's a lot of areas that these
golfers aren't going we don't need to
manage that area and transition those to
Long Grass so uh to put a ball on it
Frank sustainability for me if it's got
to start with those measurable things
those goals and then it's about what's
the least we could do and in some cases
you mentioned you need to do more to get
to your goal
um so it's not just about blanketly
eliminating the use of fertilizers or
irrigation or pesticides it's about
being a little bit more strategic in
figuring out where that line is Right
where's the the line of least uh
resources that gets me to where I want
to go
this is great Carl I couldn't I couldn't
uh support the whole idea of setting a
goal uh and and being trying to be
specific and and make it measurable and
Mike we spent a lot of time smart goals
all kinds of goals we love goals uh in
academics like crazy and I do think some
of it is because it's hard to measure
some of these things uh I I do think it
is important to set goals of things you
can measure and Carl this point is well
taken are you measuring your fuel use
how is your fuel used how much is used
to mow Fairways how much is used to mow
rough uh how much can we save if we go
to Electric what are these things and I
just think bringing some some
measurability some some standardization
to the way we look at these things is
quite a bit new uh to many parts of our
industry not all parts I mean you look
at Troon and a lot of these high-end
operations they know they mine their p's
and q's about these things and what what
you find is that environmental
sustainability tends to line up
oftentimes with economic sustainability
and it's you might save money and being
more uh sustainable from a product and
practice perspective but you might
reallocate that money uh into different
things now speaking of reallocation and
before we bring on my good friends
we want to know when that chair is not
in use Mike it's under it's it did it's
being well supervised uh I just love how
they share that space now now listen
it was a dry week across the region it
was a dry week most areas less than a
quarter of an inch across the week just
as uh we predicted uh just as we
predicted last week we got the dry
weather and and in some places it's even
starting to trigger some drought
particularly to the Southwest uh part of
the region now soils as they dry are
going to warm and so we're seeing really
good mid 50s in the New York
metropolitan area still in the 40s
Upstate but when you look around the
Rochester area Albany you start to see
some heat island effects occurring uh in
the Rochester area a lot of heat
building up in Rochester soils which I
know my old pal Jeff Corcoran is very
happy to see as the PGA Championship
will be there probably in less than a
month uh as we speak right here now Carl
really fascinating stuff I went to we're
going to chat with Mike a little bit
about fairy ring stuff as we get going I
pulled this off the uh greencast website
they've been monitoring soil temperature
here in Upstate New York at some of the
sites where they do their annual
Bluegrass Weevil monitoring and and then
typically they say fairy fairy ring
germination at 60 degrees or greater and
you know five day average you you it's
not uncommon uh to see this sort of
stuff
um I want to also talk about proxy
applications so the soils are coming the
proxy applications are still pretty good
for seed head suppression in the central
part of the Northeast region Peak seed
head flush looks like it's maybe a week
away from the Metropolitan New York area
it's just starting to come in uh down
where Mike is maybe a little bit closer
but still you're gonna find out how good
your seed head stuff worked in the next
couple of weeks right and so be mindful
of that as you move forward Dollar spot
risk estimates on the Cornell forecast
model is demonstrating an uptick AS some
rainfall potentially moves in uh into
Sunday Monday period what's very
interesting about our new forecast
website we don't use the Smith Kearns
model
but we have a daily average and you can
see a seven day average there so you can
see over a seven day period we're still
not really getting where we're worried
but in the longer day period uh I'm
sorry seven day average where but daily
you might see an uptick but you're not
seeing a trend yet so I wouldn't be in a
rush I'm not a big believer in these
early dollar spot uh applications again
for for
um specifically for uh early season
dollars by control on Fairways that's a
lot of product for something that
probably isn't there yet now the Smith
Kearns model on the greencast website is
also showing an uptick but not as much
of an uptick right it's picking it up
but it's not Amplified uh as much as our
thing and I bring this up to really you
know help people understand don't just
look at the model and say okay it says
to go I gotta go you should be looking
at a few things you should be using your
intuition this is the concept of of
finding actionable data but then
deciding ultimately how to act this
should be enhancing what you're doing
you know not giving you panic So
speaking of panic uh Ben McGraw has been
posting recently in the greencast area
and he's starting to see after a mild
year last year down in the Columbus
Central PA area a big uptick in the
annual Bluegrass Weevil populations and
and he's also saying don't panic you
know we're going to see this thing if
you're on an adult decide program which
honestly fewer and fewer people are on
all the time now more are moving to a
larval program we're starting to hear
but if you're still on an adult
population you want to wait until
there's as many out there as possible to
get the biggest Bang from your buck from
a single application one of the big
things Ben's talking about here it
doesn't appear that Forsythia synced up
with weevils this year the is definitely
something different with this
phenological indicator that I think is
really important to understand because
again if you trigger even with a
phenological indicator like Forsythia
you make your app you still may have 50
to 60 percent of the adults going to be
running around and you're going to miss
them so that's why paying attention to
these things is really important looks
like we're going to stay warm and and a
little bit dry with some rainfall maybe
coming through in the next few days but
overall even when it's going to be
cloudy and rainy in the next week to 10
days don't expect a lot of rainfall so
we're going to really find out what dry
weather is going to feel like soon and I
anticipate that's going to amplify the
annual bluegrass seed head flush they
tend to be much worse when we get dry
conditions all right Mike I know this
always isn't your favorite topic and now
you're this great scholar and I'll hold
mine up for those of us for those of you
watching on NewsChannel 10. I got my I
got my book here as well uh early
adopter I'm glad there's only a few left
we needed a new book you've been in
you've done a lot of work with fairy
rings this is a data driven application
right there are a ton of products that
you can use you know we promote the
Wisconsin website we will promote the
Kentucky uh update that's happened all
right Mike we're actually hearing quite
a bit about fairy ring getting going
this spring there's different types and
we're going to play around a little bit
with this we can cut right to the chase
on some of it but fundamentally one of
the things I want to talk to you about
is if you've got a problem with this
thing if this organism and it's so
severe that it's they're becoming
hydrophobic and you're losing Turf and
the turf is getting pitted you know
you've got to get that product down to
where the organism is if it has any
chance of
fighting a benefit because this thing is
a picture from one of your presentations
that came from Dr Henry Wetzel yeah
there you go look at this thing and see
when I see it like this I begin to
understand maybe a little bit more about
the hydrophobicity so let's take a
little bit Mike talk a little bit about
fairy ring in general and getting the
products down there to be effective
right well you know uh I've gotten a lot
of calls this spring about Ferry ring
folks have said they're they're seeing
more evidence of fairing earlier in the
season and here in the Philadelphia area
Mid-Atlantic perhaps Northeast we've had
our I guess our mild winter we didn't
have prolonged snow cover and sure soil
temperatures are warming up and fairing
the basiniomycy fungi they're just more
active and we're seeing it earlier and
this is a great photo showing the fungus
you know it was incubated for a couple
of days in a wet paper towel in a
plastic bag and the fungus fluffs out
you know Plant Pathology and it shows
you where the where the basidium icy
fungus is living right there in the
thatch it's a wood decaying fungus it
loves the lignin it's eating on it's
munching all the way at the lignin and
so making a fungicide application
uh you need to apply it and it's you
have to water it in and folks say well
how much water well you need enough
water to move that material as best you
can move the fungicide
into that that's and and even Beyond
um now our buddy John says are you
remember Dr John Cesar a University of
Florida he texted me this morning uh he
lives outside of Fort Lauderdale and
they just had a record 25.9 inches of
rain that fell and uh that would be over
watering perhaps but you do not have
water you know what I mean you do need a
lot of water and that's why I like to
recommend the fungicides tank mix with
the wedding agent to really facilitate
the placement of those fungicide
products we have some excellent
fungicides now labeled for Ferry ring
but you have to get it into that into
that that zone so to speak and punching
holes helps
or you know um I like I like needle tiny
punching on solid time punching holes
making that fungicide wedding
application and watering it in and don't
be afraid to come back uh the day after
water it in again or a couple of days
later water it in again because like you
mentioned Frank the hydrophobicity part
really kicks in that fungus is
colonizing the thatch the upper root
Zone and what you're creating is a
hydrophobic situation says it's you have
to sort of re-wet this this thatchy you
know matte material it's a challenge
that's right agronomically
and so I think one you know we have this
annual conversation and I and about
these things and it is interesting I
think the mild winter then leads to
maybe coming on earlier as the whole
system is warmer and doesn't need that
much time to warm up so it's obviously
warming quicker uh from a mild winter
now that said Mike if you have this in
particular areas you can go out and do
more targeted work on this right I mean
a lot of times these fairy rings are
very site-specific
um and and especially where they you
know where you feel like you need to
treat them so actually targeting the air
station going back and just hitting that
area with extra water is probably better
than blanketing everything uh that most
of which don't even need it and that
will sort of help you save a little bit
of resources you've I'm assuming you've
had some success in just spot treating
some of these things uh absolutely I
agree with that this these furring fungi
you know they're they're so they're so
elusive but uh when you see them on golf
courses you know they'll persist for
several years so the superintendents and
you know our course care managers our
folks they know where the fairings are
showing up and so you know treat those
areas now they come and go too sometimes
there's a golf course in central
Pennsylvania in the early 2000s they had
some varying problems on their Fairways
they had an aggressive thatch Management
program that was a nice long-term
approach so faring's been subsided but
over the last couple years it started
showing up again back on the fairways
but only certain Fairways or certain
spots on Fairways so to your point and
maybe this ties in with the
sustainability theme and Carl I really
like how you you put all that
information together
I think you can spot spot spray or
Target where you're going to make these
um these
applications especially if you gotta
utilize resources of you know Square
vacation equipment needle timing and
things and and doing specific fungicide
wedding age and tag mix applications
um and then also real quick you
mentioned the the greencast the the soil
temperature threshold
that that was actually developed there
in North at North Carolina State but it
um it does hold true I think in many
parts of the country that when he saw
temps warm up into the 5560
that just means that the basilia might
see deferring fungi they're starting to
grow and Thrive and do their thing
they're out there now
coexisting with nature and and
colonizing the fats but then you know we
get these sort of wet dry environmental
Cycles it rains it dries it rains it
dries out or with our irrigation
programs that fungus goes into its sort
of reproductive cycle that's when it
becomes hydrophobic and starts rapidly
using the batch and can break down the
organic material anyway so that's why uh
um that's uh if you're going to start a
preventatives let's say fairing program
a good way to do that start starting you
know with those soil temperatures
reached at 55 to 60 threshold just to
try yep
so so okay so this very interesting you
brought up a really interesting point
about
um a court that course in Central PA so
they had an aggressive thatch Management
program saw the ferry ring decline yes
presumably they built up a nice
um sand layer I would imagine
on the top of that yeah yeah and that
worked for a little while and now you're
saying some Fairways are getting it back
when you say elusive this organism can
be
um that's code for we don't really
understand why these things come and go
or can we say that bigger thatch areas
have more fairy ring problems that
thatch management will be uh a good
long-term solution to fairy ring
problems definitely the most severe
fairing sites I've seen with really
thick fat Slayers now having said that
I've seen other sites with minimal fats
layer and had some aggressive fairy ring
but the rule of thumb is right the more
that's the more organic matter
um they're more prone to faring uh
symptoms occurring now
um what I want to say about oh the
elusiveness there's over 60 species that
can cause varying symptoms they're on
the city you might see family they're
like a big Italian Familia you know
Frank and perhaps
um the species may have shifted on that
site in Central PA there was one
particular like the thatched and then
okay now that with the sand top dressing
and mitigation that way there could be
other species that moved in there that
acclimated to that area so
what you're telling me is we need Dan
dinelli on this job we need our band
dancing this our buddy Daniel we talk
about or you know organic radiation and
you know that's it's really endlessly
all right so listen
I got two more things to chat about one
is this idea again something I know
you've talked about in some of your
wedding agent conversations you brought
it up with fairy rings we're talking
about hydrophobicity and you guys you
and uh our partner Stan
and of course uh you know rest his soul
stands on Tech got this going too and a
lot of Johnny was involved Johnny Cesar
involved but you guys have been very
active with kale and and understanding
maybe broader effects of wedding agents
potentially on uh improving rooting now
I don't think I I would assume you know
basidomycin fungicides and rooting depth
related to wedding agents there's not a
lot there but hydrophobicity is
hydrophobicity and if you're telling me
now that using wet age it not only might
help me with uh you know localized dry
spot stuff right hydrophobicity but
potentially now increase rooting depths
in these environments that is something
I want to talk to a little bit more Mike
about and because I know you are you
know know a lot about this and I a lot
of guys use wedding agent but I don't
think a lot of people realize you could
get a potential rooting benefit from
this by using it with your fairy ring
and then continuing a program later on
let's talk about weddings no I'm glad
I'm glad you brought this up because
this this ties in with the book
specifically on chapter 15 which I think
is the best chapter in the book it's on
by the stimulus and your own Dr Frank
Rossi was a co-author of that book so
the reason I mentioned that in that
particular chapter we talk about social
factors and and we're attempting to sort
of categorize the biostimulants in the
turf industry and and Define them and
what what they're composed of and what
they do but the social fact in part is
very intriguing is research the last
recent years that looked at
the the interaction of social fact and
applications in that rhizosphere that
specific environment around the root
Zone and yes while the surfactant
technology or the molecule is helping
with the re-wedding and overcoming
hydrophobicity and allowing the root
Zone to be more wetted more uniformly
and effectively there's also a physical
chemical biological interaction with the
microorganisms around the roots how the
root hairs maintain their rigidity and
connectivity in that soil and there's
something there's been a couple of
wedding agents that have been tested
that show dramatically improve rooting
when you use them even under well
watered conditions there is even more
rooting with with the applications of a
wedding so there's something going on
there more than just wetting more than
just your traditional wedding agent and
we're diving into this a little more
with different types of research work
with our Dr Zhang there at Virginia Tech
and some controlled you know um growth
chamber studies is work out of Australia
out of a researcher there that showed
again a tremendous tremendous amount of
rooting increased rooting or enhanced
rooting and and the development of um
Improvement of rhizo sheets that
material around the roots that help the
roots uh require more water nutrients so
there's a lot of let's call them
biostimulant type effects of these some
of these wedding ages I think it's worth
exploring a lot more yeah I think it's
tied to irrigation water management and
and let's let's say yes sustain a
sustainable approach to managing water
but there's also something else going on
there I'm not saying every agent
molecule do this we need a lot more
testing but some of the ones that we've
looked at show this increased rooting
and it really got our attention and
especially in the Mid-Atlantic region
here
um where we need those roots to kind of
hang in there during the summer months
that challenging season all right listen
we're gonna wrap up here in the next
couple of minutes but I want to say I
want to say this like I said I got my
copy Carl I hope is going to get his
copy soon we we've definitely been
talking about this this is a I know you
well enough that you'll deflect a lot of
the attention to the authors right
because you obviously were heavily
involved as the editor it's your idea
and your baby for sure but it was so
great to see you number one uh approach
the topic this way Mike uh achieving
sustainable turf management this is a
publishing house out of the UK that does
this uh with a number of Industries so
like big kudos to you guys uh for
pulling this off and Carl and I have
been recently looking at you know other
work like not mowing as much work you've
been involved in
um and the chapter in here that Michelle
and Mike and Paige have worked on in the
pollinator area has been something we're
really referring to
um I'll just ask you a simple question
what was the most rewarding part about
doing this book
I appreciate you saying that I I think
it was just working with um with all the
the authors on all the different
chapters uh everyone was so gracious
with their time my goal was to to uh
learn as much as I can you know from
everyone
um and and just the interaction I had to
twist some arms to get the chapters to
me on time and I had to twist some arms
to get the edits and Corrections back
but it was a kind of rewarding
experience and I'll tell you real quick
I um I I we have such a wonderful folks
in this industry you know and and uh and
what I wanted to tie in some University
folks and Industry folks wanted
everybody's uh seated at the table here
and and contribute and I was channeling
my uh got to think about my old
professor at Penn State I did a master's
degree under Dr Don Waddington and he
was the editor of the Agronomy monograph
and I remember as a grad student he was
editing that thing and he had piles on
his desk you know of different chapters
and I had the same method what I use
different piles and different chapters
and I would edit everyone so it was It
was kind of cool like just to kind of
think back about Dr Waddington and and
how he did things and then I had good
training with Dr Peter node in Maryland
on the editing and so yeah the rewarding
part was just working with all the
authors and co-authors and yeah and it's
so great Mike we needed a we needed a
current summary of the state of the
thinking and you got this turned around
pretty quick so right now this book is
really current right we all hope in
three years it's not going to be because
we'll have a lot of new work in three
years and I think that's that's the
beauty of these things so Carl we're
getting close are there any final
questions or comments you want to make
and thank Mike before we get out of here
I appreciate that you guys thank you
yeah thanks a time for my I just want to
comment on Mike you talk about
site-specific management we talk about
it with fairy rings frankly the research
we've done on pesticide use in in the
United States that's what drives our
resource use whether it's pesticides
irrigation or fertilizer Fairway areas
where we're maintaining that quite as
intensely as greens but still pretty
intensely they're 20 or 30 Acres they
chew up a lot of resources so thinking
where we can manage those areas more
site specifically is a great comment
from Mike and I think that's that's the
lowest hanging fruit in my opinion you
could choose you could keep the same
products same program if you just
thought a little bit more about hey that
that dollar spot application do I need
to run off 30 Acres maybe hey maybe 20
acres I'll leave these 10 over here
um that's that's the key to me to start
start with uh with reducing resources
and being able to reallocate that stuff
for other uses right whether it's the
labor or the cost reallocating the other
other places in the operation
thanks for joining us Mike great to see
you thank you thank you very much thank
great to see you guys thank you thank
you
tomorrow we're going to be back with uh
Sean keister who collaborated with Mike
on some of the low mowing research we're
going to talk with Sean tomorrow from
Longwood Gardens about the
sustainability initiative so it's
sustainability week with here uh here on
the internet
last week it was Purdue and weed
scientists this week in 10 states
Pennsylvania Sean's a good guy I see you
thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu